and still no wedding day from lady gaga
and maybe she's just keeping it a secret
today we tried to get some answers from
her fiance Taylor Kinney I'm not picky
what are your only requirements for the
big day if there's some pizza
it might be tough getting that wedding
together while Taylor returns for
Chicago fires fifth season today MBC and
Fox introduced their new lineup where
the theme seems to be big stars are back
on TV
Elinor show strong cool talk about a
power duo Kristen Bell and Ted Danson's
new NBC comedy the good place is set in
the afterlife eat whatever you want
there's a ton of frozen yogurt shops
there's it's really like your idea of
perfection
JLo's shades of blue will return for its
second season she's stunned in a dated
coma cutout dress and ain't your mama
has everybody singing this is my
favorite Kardashian Andy Cohen totally
loving it when Khloe and Kourtney
Kardashian barge in on our interview I
am obsessed with the future I love that
I'm like over on Fox Queen Latifah is
headlining star about the music business
the burn cots headlines the Rocky Horror
Picture Show airing is a special in
October I shall tear and 43 years after
the movie The Exorcist is a new horror
series starring Geena Davis